so if you've been in the rails community
for any amount of time or just saw marks
clickbait title yesterday you've
probably heard the phrase rails doesn't
scale we've heard it on hacker news
we've heard NBC meetings recently we
heard it in the misguided Vanity Fair
article about Twitter with the claim
that they couldn't effectively combat
harassment because rails was just
fisher-price software it's funny they
called it that I know they meant it as
an insult saying rails was for children
are not serious adults with serious web
apps but fisher-price and rails are
alike and that they are robust
well-designed and unforgettable the
interesting thing about rail is getting
a bad rap for not being scalable is that
it's taken many companies to a scale
they never dreamed of if Twitter had
tried to build their app to handle the
scale it is today they probably would
have been bankrupt before they had a
proof of concept the reality is that
rails does scale it just doesn't scale
easily yet historically a rails hasn't
done a great job at making scaling easy
while we pride rails on developer
happiness we were missing the mark with
scaling and frankly falling short in
this talk we're gonna look at ways in
which rels was not scaling easily and
what we're going to do about it
I want scaling rails to be as enjoyable
as running the rails and you command
scaling means different things depending
on who you're talking to you or who is
trolling you or what your app is
supposed to do for the purpose of this
talk scalable means that literally over
time an applications growth and code
data and traffic doesn't really change
how well it performs while rails can't
take on every part of scaling your web
application there are two important
areas that I want to focus on the first
is that when you're scaling your web
application your test suite shouldn't
block development
as an application grows new code
shouldn't really cause a ton of friction
developers should be able to easily
prototype and build features quickly
without being hindered by the time that
it takes for your test suite to complete
well we've made many improvements to
test performance in the past it's really
no replacement for concurrent testing
the other area that rails wasn't was
failing to scale easily is that as your
application grows it should be able to
handle increased data and traffic over
time the database shouldn't just crash
because you got more users or because
you have too much data it should be easy
to distribute the load on your database
as your traffic increases rails has had
support for multiple databases but that
support is undocumented hard to
understand and difficult to implement
while rails can't take on scaling every
part of your application I believe that
we can improve the developer happiness
around these two main issues my goal is
to tackle these issues to make rails 6
scalable by default scalable by default
means that it's easy for engineers to
scale their rails application without
having to to spend hours writing a
custom set up or using a lot of outside
tools scaling your application doesn't
have to be hard and rel should be able
to take on at least some of that work
for you some of you may be thinking hold
up wait rails 5 - just came out why is
eileen talking about real stakes well
major versions of rails allow us to
reconsider what's possible it's going to
be a while before 6 is out but I wanted
to share my plans with you in the past
few months I got a lot of work to
refactor rails and add features to make
scaling easier we'll look at what the
work done to speed up your test suite
and improve rails multiple database
handling to ensure that scaling is
simple and intuitive
so the first feature that I'd like to
introduce for rl6 is parallel testing
the parallel testing feature will allow
you to run your tests concurrently using
either forked processes or threads
parallelizing test Suites is an
important part of scaling web
applications because as you add more
code and more tests you will add or
should be adding and and your testing
will become slower and slower over time
sure you can mock a bunch of calls or
ensure you're not making external
requests or building a lot a lot of
datasets but that still won't speed up
the time it takes to run 10,000 tests
linearly parallelizing large test Suites
can significantly reduce the amount of
time engineers need to wait for for your
builds to finish a lot of other
companies like github a scam and Shopify
have been writing their own parallel
testing implementation for years the
problem with all of us writing our own
implementations is we weren't sharing
our ideas with the broader community
rails is popular for taking the
complexity out of your app I'm turning
it into reusable generic chunks of code
by adding parallel testing to Rails you
can reduce the complexity of rails
applications set a standard for
parallelization and make it simple to
scale your test suite
earlier this year our patterson and i
worked together to write the parallel
testing feature rails based off the
parallel testing infrastructure and
github while inspired by the github code
the code in rails has been rewritten to
have a smaller footprint be more generic
and a lot easier to use rails parallel
testing also supports multiple databases
out-of-the-box this was a requirement
for us since we use a lot of we use
multiple databases and github in all of
our environments
the concurrent testrunner in rails six
can paralyze your test suite by using
either four processes or threads first
let's take a look at the implementation
for the forking paralyzer porch process
parallelization is implemented in rail 6
using distributed Ruby
also known as d RB d re is a distributed
object system in Ruby and can be
implemented with zero dependencies this
your new roommate is really cool and
it's one of those features that I don't
think it's a lot of attention so I
encourage you to check it out
parallelization is invoked in the in
your test your tests through the test
helper with the parallelized method this
method takes a workers argument that you
want to fork by parallelization with
working lives in active support and is
backed by many tests parallel testing
feature when you start your test suite
using the forking paralyzer the testing
parallelization class will be
initialized with the number of workers
you requested in the initialized method
we set a queue size a queue a server and
a URL instance variable the URL starts
the DRB server locally and represents
the URI for the server to bind to
parallelization and rails is supported
by mini tests so once this class is
initialized all the other methods within
the class are actually called by many
tests executor and parallel ëismí from
here mini tests will call start the
start method in the paralyzation class
starts us the empty pool array to a
block that Forks the process is based on
hue size start then calls this after
fork hook this is provided so that
active record can hook into the
parallelization and create a database
for each process start then creates a
DRB object which represents the queue of
work to perform and will maintain a
reference to the DRB server the DRB
object queue variable is used in this
loop to split the work for each process
inside the loop run one method is called
which will run the tests assigned to
that process mini tests will return a
result and the queue variable that calls
record record sends the reporter and the
result so that the end of the test suite
run each process can report which tests
passed and failed at the end of the
start method run cleanup is called the
hook is called which allows active
record to delete those temporary
databases that were created in the after
fork hook and finally mini test calls
shutdown which will empty the queue and
wait for each process to terminate and
that's basically the entire
implementation of work process parallel
testing in rails 6 as you can see the
underlying implementation is really
simple and it's only actually about 100
lines of code don't worry if you didn't
follow this though you don't actually
have to know how any of this works to
use parallel testing and rails 6 for
newly generated rails six applications
parallelization will be automatically
included in your test helper and for
upgraded applications you only need to
add a call to parallel eyes in the in
your test helper the parallel eyes
method takes a workers argument that
accepts an integer the default number of
workers is two which means that rails
will automatically fork your your tests
into two processes and create a database
for each process to run your tests
against each database is suffixed with
the worker number starting with 0 the
databases are generated in the after
after for cook that we looked at earlier
the databases are then automatically
deleted in the run cleanup hook right
before processes are terminated active
record and parallel testing does all
this work for you so you don't need to
do any of it if you're using multiple
databases in your relic ation we else
provides to call that cooks to handle
your secondary or third or fourth or
hundredth database the paralyse setup is
called via after fork and can be used to
set up your secondary database the
parallelized teardown method is called
by the run cleanup hook and can be used
to clean up your work databases I get
hope we have a whole lot of complicated
code to make this happen so once you run
rails 6 this is going to be a very
welcome abstraction
if you're using a single database as
most applications are then you don't
need to use these hooks because rails
will automatically create and delete the
databases in apps when as you're running
the tests as you can see the API for
Forks paralyzation is relatively simple
and easy to use so the other type of
parallel testing that rails 6 provides
is threaded you'll want to use threads
in accrete over processes and a few
cases you'll need threads if you're
using Windows because the UNIX sockets
that DRB relies on aren't supported and
you'll also want to use threads if
you're a jrb user the last reason that
you may want to use threads is of your
tests or i/o bound most of your tests
are not IO bound but if they are they're
going to be faster with the threaded
paralyzer because they won't be waiting
for the processes to finish before
running the next thing the caveat though
is though that your code has to be
thread safe to use the threaded
paralyzer the parallelized method takes
a second optional argument that default
called with the defaults to processes to
use the threaded paralyzer in your
application set with two threads it's
that simple
the paralyzation setup and teardown
hooks are not supported by the threaded
paralyzer because it only uses a single
database one thing to keep in mind is
that running tests in the same suite
cannot use different types of
parallelization or number of workers you
can't pass 5 workers to a hundred of
your tests using threads and processes
for three workers to the rest if you
need that kind of behavior you should
split your tests in the two different
Suites threaded parallelization rl6
uses many tests threaded executor one of
the differences between the
implementation of worked process
paralyzer and the threaded paralyzer is
that we didn't have to write any of the
code for the threaded paralyzer in the
test suite many tests paralyzer uses
threads already so we simply just added
a conditional that initialized that
executor instead of rails paralyzer
so originally Aaron I originally didn't
want to implement the threaded paralyzer
because frankly threads are really hard
to get right but I felt it was important
to support threads out of the box for
our JRuby and Windows users an example
of why threads are hard came up while
Aaron and I were working on the threaded
paralyzer we were running our tests and
we were suddenly seeing that everything
was sort of randomly failing deadlocks
sometimes data was left behind it was
really strange some runs would pass but
almost all of them would fail we first
thought it was related to the fact that
my demo app that we were running the
tests in was using multiple databases so
I switched to a brand new app that had a
single test database but we saw the same
issues running a single test always
passed so we knew that it was something
to do with concurrency to look deeper at
the problem we hacked the test log to
display the connection ID for each
connection to the database each thread
should be connecting to the test
database but with its own connection ID
oh we saw instead was quite opposite and
quite wrong each thread was connecting
to the database with the same connection
ID and Aaron says to me this is so weird
all the databases are using the same ID
we seem to have an isolation problem and
as they said those words I suddenly knew
that it was all my fault I realized in
that moment that code I wrote in rails a
year ago was coming back to haunt me how
many of you in this room remember system
tests well when I implemented system
tests I wanted to do it in such a way
that we didn't need to use database
cleaner anymore the underlying problem
was that one system tester run rails
opens a connection to the database on
one thread and then capybara boots a
puma server which opens a second thread
and second connection to the database
this meant that in system test rails
thread and the Puma thread couldn't see
each other and we would get inconsistent
data between test runs because the
transaction and the rails thread didn't
know about the data on the Puma thread
to roll it back the way we fix this
problem was to force each thread to use
the same connection
do you see where I'm going with this the
change that I implemented a fixed system
test is the exact change that broke
parallelization because the because the
change required rails to tell all the
threads to use the same database
connection with parallel testing we want
the exact opposite of that behavior
because the threads aren't trying to
share data but and transactions like
system tests are for effective threaded
concurrency each individual thread
should maintain its own connection to
the database so that the threads aren't
influencing data on each other
luckily since I implemented the
offending code it was easy to find and
fix the problem I simply added the
ability to internally configure the
setting so if you're using thread the
threaded paralyzer the threads will each
open a separate connection to the
database this does mean that system
testing is probably not possible with
the threaded paralyzer I mean I know it
doesn't actually work there might be a
way to make it work but I didn't do that
considering that the change to fixtures
for the system test threads is the exact
opposite behavior of the bit of what we
need for the threaded paralyzer I don't
know how well they would have worked
even if I hadn't broken them in this way
if you want to use the one use
parallelization with system tests I do
know that processes works so running
your paralized tests doesn't require any
extra work on your part after you set
them up in your test helper simply run
rails tests like you normally would and
rails will handle the rest for you
sometimes you may want to change the
number of workers depending on the
environment you're using for example you
may want to use two workers locally but
14 workers on CI so rails provides an
environment variable called parallel
workers which will take precedence over
the number of work of workers passed as
a keyword argument if the number of
workers is one or fewer paralyzation
will not be implemented because you need
more than one worker for it to actually
function
if you're interested in the PR for
parallel testing you can check it out on
github parallel testing is going to be a
great feature for improving the speed of
your test suite I'm really excited for
this feature and I hope that it helps
you scale your applications test suite
so that you can focus on deploying code
instead of waiting for CI to finish now
that we've got your test suite squared
away let's take a look at the other way
that rails doesn't handle scaling well
today and that's whether your
application can handle a spike in
traffic I'm not talking about DDoS
traffic for that kind of spike you want
to use an outside vendor or hire experts
that can mitigate that for you what I'm
talking about is trying to scale your
web application because Justin Bieber
came along and started using it we need
to scale fast and you need to scale
yesterday I've been in these situations
before and it's not fun you're just
waking up and starting work and suddenly
Nagios is just yelling at you and you
realize that your single primary MySQL
database just isn't cutting it there are
too many reads and too many writes and
you know your database is about to take
your application down it's at this point
you know that you need to split tables
off your main my sequel cluster you need
read and write and read-only databases
you need replication and you need more
capacity your single primary database
won't cut it anymore where else has had
support for multiple databases for a
while in that you can do it we do it at
github so it is possible but it's hard
really hard it's so hard that it took me
three hours to build multiple databases
into a demo app in rails 5 and I already
have done it before I don't know how
long it would take someone who's never
worked on this kind of stuff the reason
it's hard is that rails hasn't been
setting a standard while the underlying
plumbing works great we weren't exposing
it through good documentation or the
tools that you need to make it intuitive
so the second rail sticks highlight that
we're going to talk about our
improvements to using multiple databases
with rails while these aren't punchy
brand new features like parallel testing
they're an important part of scaling
your web application multiple databases
are useful if your application is
getting to a point where a single
database instance can't handle all of
the traffic reading and writing from it
if your application is going down
because your database is crashing you
may need to split tables off into
separate clusters or add read replicas
to relieve e.8 pressure on your primary
database I get hub we have multiple
top-level primary databases that have
write roles as well as read replicas for
each of them rails has for a long time
supported multiple databases and thanks
to work from Arthur Neves and Matthew
Draper rails 5 is a ton easier than it
was in rails 3 or 4 however when I set
out to build that demo app that uses
multiple databases I quickly realized
there's a lot missing let's take a look
at what an application when multiple
databases looks like and along the way
I'll point out where rails was failing
to make it easy let's say we have an
application with two databases all right
when is our primary database that has a
flowers and peoples table and the second
is an animal's database with a cats and
dogs table by default active record
knows about the primary database and
connection because that's attached to
active record base we need to tell our
application how to connect to and talk
to the animals database however before
we get started working on our
application we already have a problem
best practices for multiple databases
aren't documented in rails we have no
documentation for how to set up your
database you know your models and
connections your migrations or your rate
tests for the second database based on
our setup at github I originally set up
my database UMO like this here we have a
two-tier configuration with the default
production namespace and a second
namespace called production animals for
the animals production database well
this way may make sense or may be the
way that previous blog posts have said
to do it it's no longer the recommended
to set up your database yeah well for
multiple databases if you're using rails
5 or higher and you need multiple
databases you should set up here our
database yeah well using three tiers
like this the three tier config allows
us to group all of our databases by
their respective environment this leads
to a cleaner database llamó and it makes
it easier to understand how everything
works together primary is the default
for your main database this technically
can be called anything but I really just
recommend you keeping it primary so it
makes sense this would represent your
original production database then we
have the animals entry which will hold
all of the dogs and cats tables with the
three tier config we know exactly what
databases are tied to the production
environment versus how the two tier can
finish to work don't worry though
if you're using a two tier config or
you're using a single database per
environment you don't need to change
your config it's just if you're using
three multiple databases once we have
the database is created we need to tell
active record where the migrations for
the dogs and cats tables live so I
worked with migrations that deal with
multiple databases before and there's a
few ways to do it you can hack your
migrations to set the connection at the
beginning of the migration this is the
way we do that github and I can tell you
that I do not recommend it so my
preferred way is to put all of the
migrations in the animal for the animals
database in their own directory it's
cleaner and easier to group connections
migrations by connection rather than
putting everything in the DB migrate
directory and having to like open each
migration file to figure out where the
table lives for this app I moved the
dogs and cats migrations into a
directory called animals migrate to use
this way of handling migrations however
we need to set my migrations paths
anytime we're going to call migrate this
works fine for the custom break tasks
but it's impossible to use with any of
the existing code in rails because the
migrations paths is a class method or
was a class method on migrator instead
of a method on the connection instance
this means that every time we want to
call migrate for animals we have to set
the migrations paths
so we've discovered the second problem
with multiple databases in rails rebbe's
doesn't really support migrations for
multiple connections you can write a
database tasks that will run the
migrations for you but if any of you
need any of the rails internals that
depend on the migrations path you have
they have no awareness of anything
outside of the DB migrate directory so
the next step is setting up animals
connection for the dog cat models first
we create a new base class you can name
it whatever you want but I named it
animal space for this to function
correctly we need to set abstract class
to true this setting tells active record
not to use the implied STI table from
the parent class for the child classes
for example we don't want the dog model
to look in animals based dogs table we
want it to look in the dogs table then
we need to establish a connection to
animals and that's it now that our
animals base is set up we need to change
our child classes that to inherit from
animals base instead of application
record this tells rails which connection
to use when you call dog new or cat dot
fine to make sure that it looks in the
animals database rather than primary so
while we've already discovered some
problems with setup this looks all
pretty simple right the caveat though is
that none of the rake tasks will work
for your secondary database the tasks
only know about active record base and
have no understanding of animals base
create drop and migrate will only
operate on your primary database and not
on the animals one so we're going to
have to write all of those ready tests
for each non primary database writing
all those tasks is tedious and
time-consuming this is something that
rails should be this is something that
you should not have to do rails should
really be doing it for you after I
created all the rake tasks which was
probably two and a half of the three
hours that took me to set this up I went
to run the room I went to run the create
tasks for the primary database and my
application through an error saying that
the production database wasn't
configured I double-checked my rake
tests and even stashed all of my work
except for the three tier config to
double-check that I had done
Hunn done anything wrong
after some debugging I found that the
default connections weren't working with
the three tier config when you call rate
DB create it first loads that octave
record initializer railtie which calls
establish connection with no arguments
this is where rails will establish the
default connection to the database in a
standard application with a two-tier
config rails we'll assume that you want
the database that corresponds with the
environment but when we have a two-tier
config rails doesn't know which one is
the default because there are two per
our environment primary and animals so
now now we've defined four areas where
active record is making scaling your
database very hard there's no
documentation migrations don't work
database tasks don't exist and the
default connection doesn't even work at
this point I realize the multiple
databases in rails applications are
still really hard I know what I'm doing
and I've worked on the like not even
just multiple databases in an applet the
plumbing of multiple databases before
and I still couldn't quickly set up
multiple databases in a demo up rails
wasn't meeting the basic criteria to
make scaling or database easy the scope
of my original project upstream some of
the github multiple database behavior to
Rails had grown enormous Li and it
started to look like I was going to have
to do a massive yak shave to accomplish
what I wanted except instead of having
one problem to solve I had three massive
y-axis shades each of these problems was
going to be time-consuming and there was
no easy way to solve any of them it's
easy in situations like this to get
overwhelmed and frustrated and believe
me quite a few times I had wondered why
I'd even tried to upstream any of yet
hubs multiple database behave behavior
two rails at all but then I remembered
that I proposed to talk to railsconf and
then they asked me to keno and so there
is no way I was gonna back out of that
so the first thing I decided to fix was
handling for migrations it didn't make
sense to start with fixing documentation
because shaving all the other yaks was
going to change how multiple databases
work anyway I chose to work on
migrations because parallel testing
needed to support multiple databases and
I knew that the parallelized hooks were
going to work better if I could fix the
migration code
previously if you wanted to put your
migrations in a separate folder you had
to set the migrations paths anytime you
were going to call migrate and write
your own fancy custom tasks this is fine
if you're calling migrate directly but
if you want to rely on any of the rails
internals it becomes impossible to set
the to set the that path since there's
no way to tell rails what migrations
paths to use except for on the class
level this means that your app is always
responsible for telling rails where the
migrations paths live because rails
can't ask where they are it should be
easier to work with multiple with
migrations in different directories I
decided the best way to fix migrations
was to store the migrations paths on the
connection instead of the class so that
rails can ask the model where do my
migrations live instead of having to be
told by the app every single time it
needed to run migrations to accomplish
this Aaron and I were factored in
migrations paths and you can now set
migrations paths in your database demo
all you need to do is change your app
and the database yamo to set migrations
paths to the database to the file
directory that you created so we can set
ours to the DB animals migrate if you
don't set this field rails will default
to DB Margaret this we're factoring
moves the information for migrations
paths from the migrator class onto the
connection this change makes makes it
possible for active record to ask the
connection what migrations paths it
should use before this change this
wasn't possible
this looks like a very simple change but
required a medium-sized super factoring
to accomplish we drastically reduced the
private API for the migrator class which
allows for more flexibility and
controlling wear migrations are run from
it's also backwards compatible so you
don't actually have to change anything
in your app until you want to use this
feature looking at we're factoring PRS
aren't fun for conference talks so if
you're interested in the implementation
you can check out the pull request on
github alright so now that one yak was
done it was time to take on the next one
changing rails so that you no longer had
to write all of the rate tasks for your
new database one of the hardest parts
about multiple databases and rails is
that you have to write all of the rate
tasks for your animals database yourself
this is extremely time consuming and
something that rel should really be
doing for you
my goal is with these improvements were
to make the database tasks intuitive and
predictable the problem with the
existing tasks were the code or DB drop
migrating create would only operate on
the primary database that doesn't seem
very intuitive if I were an create I
expected to create all of them and there
were known there were no namespace tasks
for primary animals respectively so even
if I fix the first problem there was
gonna not risk I'm not going to be any
way to have just to run migrate on your
animals database or drop on your primary
I wanted the existing tasks like rate DB
drop migrate create schema dump schema
load all of those to automatically run
for both the primary and animals
databases with a three-tier config they
were only running from the primary
database one of the challenges with
dealing with a three-tier config is that
a lot of the code in rails assumes that
we have a two-tier config and the config
hash is tied to an environment when you
have a single database per environment
rails will simply select a single
configuration hash that corresponds to
their respective respected requested
environment but with a three-tier config
requesting a configuration hash by an
environment will return the configs for
that environment return all the configs
from that environment so we don't know
which one is the default
with the three tier config we also don't
know how many databases there are per
environment or what their namespaces are
configuration as hashes are in a
flexible data model because rails can't
easily select the animals database for
an environment because rails doesn't
know what the namespace of that database
is set to so to solve this problem Aaron
and I decided that we should internally
convert the hashes to objects so that we
can ask them questions and weren't
easily manipulate the data we created a
new class called database config with
this class we can pass an environment
that would correspond with the
environment and the first level of the
hash a specification name for the second
level that corresponds to the to the
namespace like primary or a nor animals
and it configure hash which or config
which corresponds to the configuration
hash for that environment and
specification respectively the return
object looks like this now that we have
this object we can ask you questions
what environment is this config for what
specification name is associated with
this configuration and what config hash
is associated with the database these
objects are created by passing the
entire database yam will hash to a
method called DB configs this method
walks all of the configurations in the
database and returns the database config
objects now that we have these objects
it's easy to manipulate the data model
we can collect the configs for an
environment using a new method called
configs for there's nothing but collect
all the configs for a specified
environment by iterating over the
objects by a turing over the objects
return in DB configs if a block is given
it can fix what will return a spec spec
name that corresponds with the
configuration hash and it can earn a
corresponding configuration hash if a
block is not given that can fix for
we'll return an array of of configs for
that environment so in the case of our
application that we looked at earlier if
we pass production to the two configs or
we will get an array of database objects
for the primary and animals production
databases
by converting the hashes to objects we
have more flexibility and control over
the return data we can ask the objects
questions or enumerate over the return
database configs with fruit pie or find
this gives us the ability to more easily
manipulate these objects let's take a
look at how we use them in our to fix
the database commands in rails 5 then
migrate tasks look like this it's simply
loaded the config and called migrate
because it relied on the existing
database connection this method would
only migrate the primary database in a
3-tier config to change this to migrate
both the primary and animals database we
use the configs form method to iterate
over the databases and migrate them
first they pass the rail rails
environment to configs 4 which will
recollect the configs tied to that
environment when using a block and fix
or we return the spec and config we
don't need the spec name so we just have
the underscore then we establish a
connection using that return config and
then we can call migrate which will
migrate all the databases because of the
migrations paths our factoring rails
knows exactly where your migrations live
so we can run the migrations for the
primary and animals database
respectively once it gets to that
database in the loop the changes for
drop create and migrate commands are
basically the same collect all the key
things for the request an environment
loop through them establish a connection
and perform the request into action now
all of these tasks will operate on all
of your databases so now that these
tests operated in a predictable way it
was time to build the dynamic tasks for
each database in the configuration I
wanted the tasks for each database to be
easy to discover and symbol to use to do
this I decided the best way was to
suffix the database commands with the
database name space this way they're
intuitive because they read like English
hey database create animals and are easy
to discover because they show up in the
rake tasks list these tasks are useful
if you want to operate on just one of
your databases for a specific
environment this would allow you to drop
the animals database but not the primary
or migrate the primary database and not
animals this gives you the same
flexibility that you have an same
flexibility and a multiple
a base application that you have in a
single database application to
accomplish this we collect all of the
configs name config names inside the
migrated namespace loop through all of
the specification names to create the
name taste names based tasks then using
the spec name and environment we request
the configuration with config for engine
spec this will return a single database
config object based on the environment
and specification name from there we
establish a connection using the using
the config so that we're attached to the
correct database and finally migrate
that database
this doesn't look complicated but trust
me figuring out all the required pieces
and we're factoring that we needed to do
to make these tasks automatically create
themselves took a really long time I'm
not going to show you all of the tasks
and how I wrote them because they're all
generally generally the same for each
database we create a command that loops
through the configs create the namespace
of the task and then calls the methods
for that task if you're interested in
the PR for the majority of this work you
can find it on github fixing migrations
and adding improvements to the rake
tasks drastically improves the
experience for multiple databases and
rails these changes create an intuitive
experience for working with multiple
databases there's still a ton of work to
do to make multiple databases truly
scale and rails but these changes are
big difference
as you know we still have one yak left
to shave the fact that default
connections for three-tier configs don't
quite work I've added a band-aid fix for
this problem but I know that it is not
correct and I'm trying to fix it the
right way after trying to force rails to
work as is we've come to the conclusion
that we need to spend time with
factoring active records connection
handling to be able to actually
accomplish what we want Aaron and I are
working on changing active records
underlying connection management to use
the database config objects that we
looked at earlier this will allow us to
more easily select the config that we
actually want to connect to this is a
huge undertaking and connection
management in rails has worked from a
slightly larger yak into my personal
white whale one day I will defeat it but
that work is neither complete and we're
interesting to look at I hope that next
year at railsconf that I can talk to you
about all the features that are now that
will be possible after we finish this
for factoring there's a ton more work to
do to make multiple databases in rails
actually simple to use I want to add
nice API as her readwrite splitting some
performance improvements and that
documentation that we talked about
earlier my hope is that the work that's
been done so far and the connection
management refactoring inspires more
changes to scaling the database side of
our rails applications I'd like to thank
my friend and co-worker Aaron Patterson
for working with me on these features
he started the work on parallel testing
and helped me navigate connection
management in rails I not have finished
any of these features if it wasn't for
his help so a couple weeks ago someone
asked me aren't you concerned that rails
will become bloated with all of this
scaling code this is a valid point most
apps don't need github scale but when I
look at the ways in which github has
forced rails to scale over the years I
can't help but wonder well would rails
look like if we'd upstream these
features five years ago
what more apps be using parallel testing
and multiple databases would we still be
saying rails doesn't scale or with me
instead me asking how can we make real
scale even more this past year at github
I worked on upgrading our application
from rails 3 to 4 to through that work I
got to see all the parts of github stack
from git code to wiki's to just a pull
request to help get it get actually
works to our database infrastructure I
see eye to eye in our deployment code I
got to see all of the decisions made
over the last 10 years the good ones and
the bad ones that scaled github to where
we are now I know that we're not the
only ones who forced rails to scale I
worked on a custom multiple database
setup and parallel testing and other
companies before github I know that
Shopify has their own multiple database
and parallel testing setup as well I
started to wonder why we were all built
the same tools but we weren't sharing
with each other and I think that comes
from when we the Royal we I don't I'm
not passing blame on to anybody specific
here think that our scaling problems are
unique and special this thinking means
that when we're tackling problems in our
application we tend to look inward for a
solution you've got to fix that bug or
that performance issue we need multiple
databases and rails doesn't support it
our engineer's are complaining about CI
time we need a fix in that fix needs to
be done yesterday these kinds of
emergencies caused us to spend time
writing band-aid fixes instead of
building a scaling solution upstream
when we're in a stressful situation it's
easy to say let's just fix this now and
we'll come back and build it right later
but later never comes these patches have
a way of taking on a life of their own
and they grow and they grow and they
grow until you don't know where your app
ends and your framework begins our
applications begin to resemble a game of
Jenga one wrong move and the whole thing
comes down
and when that happens we start to think
that maybe they were right
maybe rails doesn't scale but what's not
scaling is the code that we wrote
instead of building generic tools
upstream we build more and more on top
of our fragile application when we build
tools while only looking inward our code
becomes specialized rigid and impossible
to change the tools we built stagnate
because they don't benefit from
community improvement on top of that we
end up building the same tools over and
over again there's a better way though
we need to start looking at our problems
from an upstream first point of view the
first step is the mitting that our
applications aren't special if our
applications are successful we're all
going to need to scale so why are we
boarding the solutions to those problems
I've seen many companies reinvent
parallel testing hack together multiple
database handling and force their apps
to scale inside their application rather
than building a scaling solution
upstream I'm not claiming that up
streaming is easy but when we see
ourselves building the same patterns
over and over again it's time to ask is
this problem truly unique to my
application and when it's not it should
be upstream to rails or built as open
source upstream your boat your code
burst has many benefits to your
organization in your community up
streaming your tools forces you to write
generic code this prevents your
application from becoming tightly
coupled to your tools which will keep
your code more flexible and easier to
change less like Jenga or like Legos up
streaming scaling solutions means that
you're training your future workforce
your engineers don't need to learn how
to implement multiple databases for your
setup because your setup is everyone's
setup rails will set the standard from
scaling databases so you don't need to
redefine that standard at each new
company you work at or each new
application you build and lastly an
upstream first mind set means that we're
giving back to the community and that
community gives back to you
when you push your code upstream you
stop porting solutions that aren't
unique to your application and others
are able to use your tools and improve
upon them
this is what makes over source of
magical I know that my upstream multiple
database handling that not only will
other companies benefit from it they're
going to improve it for me too so I can
do less work later working by yourself
in a vacuum isn't fun when you share
your experience and your code with
others you learn from their experiences
four years at github we've been hacking
our application to scale and it's time
that we started giving back and sharing
our experience with the community in
order to improve rail scaling ability I
looked at all the ways in which we force
rels to scale at github I've worked on
these tools before but seeing them at
github scale really showed me how much
rails was missing over the last ten
years github has learned a lot from
using rails we've learned where it
stands up and we learned where it falls
down and now we're giving back and up
streaming that scaling behavior because
we know it's not special by building
these tools and rails we reduced the
footprint of our application train our
future work force and give back to the
community I want everyone who uses rels
to experience that developer happiness
not just at the rails new command but
five ten and fifteen years later but
they can only continue to experience
that happiness if rails is providing the
tools they need to run their application
for 5 10 15 20 and 25 years so to answer
the question do I think rails will
become bloated with scaling code my
answer is no because contrary to popular
opinion rails isn't dying
it's maturing if rails wants to continue
to be the choice for web applications we
the rails team need to respond to the
needs of those applications we need to
be built not just for prototypes before
the long term the past to maturing is to
start building scaling solutions
upstream so that our users don't need to
constantly reinvent the wheel or worse
look elsewhere
some may still think that rails is just
fisher-price software but like I said
earlier fisher-price and rails are both
well-designed robust and unforgettable
we'll keep adding improvements to Rails
to make it more scalable more resilient
more unforgettable we'll take your apps
from rails new to Rails scale will keep
improving rails until everyone is saying
rails does scale but to do that I need
your help I want you to go home and look
at your applications what have you done
to force rails to scale for you what can
you give back to our community can you
make parallel testing faster do you have
other things in your multiple database
handling that I don't know about do you
do you have other tools that you built
that can be made generic and pushed
upstream rails is and will continue to
be defined by its community help us to
find the future of rails
let's make rl6 scalable by default thank
you
[Applause]